[Musique]
bonsoir à tous à tous bienvenue pour
deux heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 6 juillet une
longue réunion d' écoute mais pas de
décision à ce stade des organisations
syndicales et patronales étaient reçus
par emmanuel macron ce mardi sur la
table le dossier explosif de la réforme
des retraites que l'exécutif n'entend
pas dramatiser au menu également la
lutte contre les inégalités économiques
et la relance post co vide
pas de trêve pour la violence par armes
à feu à chicago même durant le week-end
de la fête nationale
un indépendante cei sanglant pour la
troisième ville du pays avec quelques 14
personnes tuées et 74 blessées
gangrénés par des guerres de gangs la
ville se désespèrent d'être devenue la
championne de cette violence que joe
biden qualifie d'épidémies et de honte
internationale
le plus gros fonds de pension norvégien
qu'elle pn on se désengager de ces
entreprises présentes dans les colonies
israéliennes en cisjordanie dont les
français alstom et altice fort de ses 80
milliards d'euros d'actifs le groupe
considère que la présence de ces
entreprises contribuent à une violation
du droit humain international au sein
des territoires occupés d action saluée
par les palestiniens mais que l'état
hébreu n'a pour l'instant pas commenté
[Musique]
les partenaires sociaux à l'elysée
aujourd'hui une réunion je cite des
comptes avant de possibles annonces plus
tard en juillet principal dossier le
plan de relance économique post crise
sanitaire mais aussi et surtout en toile
de fond le brûlant dossier de la réforme
des retraites alors qu emmanuel macron
doit s'exprimer à ce sujet d'ici au 14
juillet ont fait le point avec lucas
léger devant le palais présidentiel
bonsoir le cas quelles étaient
précisément le but de cette rencontre
et bien c'est rencontre déjà à la durée
3 heures entre les membres du
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
il y avait présence bien sûr le
président mais aussi le premier ministre
jean castex le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire ou la ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes avec les représentants
des principaux syndicats comme la cfdt
la cgt fo la cftc ou la cftc est bien
sûr aussi les représentants du patronat
comme le medef où la cgpme
donc oui parmi tous les sujets qui ont
été abordés il y en a et épineux bien
sûr c'est celui des retraites la réforme
avait été suspendue avec la crise du
commis de 19 en 2020 mais avant cela
elle avait déclenché de fortes
contestations même une grève dans les
transports à le prévoyez notamment la
suppression des 42 régime qui existe
pour le remplacer par un système à
points le gouvernement évoque depuis
plusieurs depuis plusieurs jours et bien
la possibilité que cette réforme soit
reprise je vous propose notamment
d'écouter isabelle bande qui a parlé
après cette rencontre
une réforme des retraites est nécessaire
pour faire évoluer notre système vers un
verre plus d'universalité d'équité et de
soutenabilité et c'est pour cette raison
que nous devrons travailler un peu plus
longtemps dans les années qui viennent
mais c'est dans les changes avec les
français les organisations syndicales et
patronales et les forces politiques que
nous trouverons les bonnes réponses
mais côté syndicats on ne veut pas
entendre parler d'un allongement de la
durée du travail ni pour la fin de ce
quinquennat ni pour un prochain jeu vous
propose notamment d'écouter le
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
avant qu'il entre à cette réunion je
pense que c'est le bon timing personnes
salariés n'en veulent pas ils l'ont
signifié de sur le plan
économie sociale je mets 10 la priorité
des priorités c'est une fois j'ai
suffisamment expliqué avant même la
crise sanitaire
la solution aux retraites et c'est
l'emploi s'est même chose sur
l'assurance chômage
3 je ne pense pas que ça serait la
meilleure des idées que d'en faire un
enjeu électoraliste
le président a déclaré en juin que de
toute façon c'est très fort mais bien
elle ne pourrait pas être appliqué dans
sa forme de 2020 mais sans plus de
détails il devait il devrait préciser sa
position d'ici le 14 juillet et
peut-être annoncé un plan pour la mise
en place de cette réforme
mais dans ce plan est bien une grande
inconnue pour s inviter la crise ducobu
de 19
merci le cas légers en direct de
l'elysée la réforme donc explosive des
retraites qui revient donc sur la table
à moins d'un an désormais d'élection
présidentielle
elle se veut bon timing après une annus
horribilis et surtout at on vraiment
besoin de cette réforme c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir
et avec nous pour en débattre
yves contassot membre d'europe écologie
les verts à ses côtés stéphane pelé
vice-président du mouvement la france
vraiment bonsoir messieurs bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france donc on l'aura
compris évidemment pas mal de crispation
dans la cour de l'elysée d'ailleurs
partout à la plupart des syndicats ne
sont pas très enthousiastes à l'idée de
discuter de cette réforme des retraites
alors que plane toujours la menace
épidémique
on va avant de vous faire réagir les
gouttes et laurent berger le patron de
la cfdt qui menacent même de mobiliser
ses troupes à la rentrée prendre des
décisions aujourd'hui c'est plus que
prématurée ça serait même hors de propos
dans la période que nous sommes en train
de vivre je crois que je crois même que
avoir dit qu'il y avait un risque social
et démocratique
un stéphane telle est en tout cas un
relèvement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite dont ne veut pas laurent berger
c'est vraiment pas le moment est ce
qu'il ya un risque social et
démocratique le gouvernement doit se
lancer malgré tout ce que je dirai
simplement ce soir c'est que un
président ne devrait pas faire ça d'une
manière générale un président ne devrait
pas mener une réforme tambour battant
six mois avant une consultation majeur
une consultation nationale et à
président ne devrait pas non plus ne pas
réformer ce qu'il a fait pendant cette
période
donc oui il était à la tête du pays
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
très probablement il ya une toute autre
méthode à adopter par contre je dois le
dire est très probablement c'est pour ça
que vous avez parlé d'un face à face ce
soir même si ici je suis au nom d'un
mouvement plutôt représentative des
citoyens et qui n'est pas sur une
attitude partisane mais évidemment moi
je représente plutôt le camp de ceux qui
veulent une réforme tout simplement
parce que le système actuel est injuste
le système actuel permet à des
professions on va dire protéger à près
de 50 de régimes spéciaux de vivre une
retraite relativement apaisé tranquille
et tant mieux pour eux ils l'ont bien
mérité mais surtout ça n'attire aucun
jeune dans la voie professionnelle moi
je ne veux
aucun jeune français un jeune qui
s'engage sur le marché du travail
s'engagent simplement au vu du système
de retraites qu'il connaîtra dans
quelques décennies tout ça était valable
dans une toute autre époque
à l'époque où il fallait attirer les
gens sur le monde du travail vous le
savez les régimes spéciaux par exemple
celui de la sncf a été créée par des
sociétés privées dans les années 20
parce qu'elle voulait attirer des jeunes
en france partout pour poser des rails
c'était des métiers très difficile tout
ça n'existe plus nous sommes plutôt dans
une période où malheureusement il ya
beaucoup moins d'actifs par rapport au
nombre de retraités donc il faut
répartir maintenant autrement le fruit
du travail et c'est pour ça que je pense
que aller vers un régime universel est
une bonne chose mais par contre
s'engager dans un débat est peut-être je
vais je vais l'essayer fréquentation que
je salue donc prendre la parole et je
reviendrai peut-être sur la méthode tout
à l'heure mais je pense qu'il faut une
toute autre méthode avec notamment une
méthode de concertation des français qui
fera l'objet d' ailleurs un grand débat
pendant la période de campagne
électorale
on va revenir évidemment sur la méthode
mais aussi sur le fond du débat ce qu'on
en a vraiment besoin de cette réforme
est tout d'abord sur l'opportunité de
les mener avant la fin du quinquennat
yves contassot est-ce que emmanuel
macron doit se lancer on rappelle quand
même que c'était l'une de ses promesses
principal de campagne on l'a vu sur le
dossier des retraites
emmanuel macron a voulu passer en force
avec l'adoption de sa réforme avec ce
qu'on appelle le 49-3 c'est à dire
l'impossibilité pour les parlementaires
de s'exprimer et de voter donc on n'est
pas du tout dans la concertation dans
l'élaboration d'un projet nécessaire
sans doute mais pas comme il est prévu
de faire qu'en fait c'est pas un aliment
en améliorant le sort des gens qui est
proposé c'est au contraire une baisse
générale si on veut s'aligner vers le
bas supprimant les régimes spéciaux qui
pour certains sont effectivement plus
favorable que le régime général à tous
l'au delà et deuxièmement avec les là où
on le voit bien avec ça ce débat sur le
report de l'âge de la retraite de l'âge
yann c'est de faire baisser le coût de
la retraite il ne s'en cache pas c'est
son seul objectif est qu un discours
assez scandaleux d'ailleurs sur les
retraités sont riches quand on regarde
le minimum vieillesse ce qu'on appelle
le minimum vieillesse 900 euros par mois
c'est ça et riche le la retraite moyenne
en france moins de 1300 euros nets par
mois et pour les femmes c'est 32 % de
moins que pour les hommes
c'est sale et riche et ses chiffres ce
sont les chiffres officiels du
gouvernement de l'insee du conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui dit lui
même comme va avoir modification du
rapport et le nombre de retraités qui va
s'améliorer dans les années à venir et
donc on fait la proposition enfin c'est
ce que faire monsieur macron purement
conjoncturelle il faut lire le rapport
du cor il est extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'il dit lui même qu'il n'ya pas
eu de dégradation de la couverture des
retraites malgré la crise économique
pour plein de raisons et donc on voit
bien que tout ça est purement dans la
même logique toujours réduire réduire
réduire le pouvoir d'achat au sens large
le pouvoir de vivre des personnes en
france
avec cette espèce de discours classique
il faut réduire tout ce qui vient du
public et favoriser le privé
n'oubliez pas que derrière ce voile à
toutes les compagnies d'assurance qui
pousse en dix ans sortons du régime des
retraites tel qu'il existe en france
depuis près d'un siècle maintenant 80
ans pour passer à un régime de type
américain régime d'assurance
individuelle c'est ça qui est derrière
ça a laissé répondre stéphanie paulet
faux pas je crois que pour pour répondre
à une question d'une telle portée parce
qu'on le dit toujours c'est la mère des
réformes cette réforme des retraites
tout simplement parce que on vit plus
longtemps et on aspire à une retraite
heureuse et donc évidemment que c'est un
problème essentiel dans la vie de tous
les français mais pour aborder ces
questions là ces réformes là il ne faut
pas exagérer
d'ailleurs yves contassot lui même vient
de dire pourquoi il faut réformer tout
simplement parce que le minet
vieillesse est bien trop bas parce que
les gens rentrés dans la carrière tard
avec des études très longues se retrouve
à des niveaux de retraite trop faible
parce que des femmes par exemple qu'ils
ont une carrière interrompue à plusieurs
reprises se retrouver avec des retraites
effet très faibles donc c'était toute
une série d'avancées possible avec une
réforme des retraites mais pour réformer
cela il fallait aller vers un nouveau
système et c'est pour ça que moi
j'apprécie les grandes
comment dire les grandes envolées de
monsieur contassot je pense que nous
pourrions être d'accord sur un certain
nombre de principes mais pas sur le fait
qu' on ne peut pas maintenir le système
tel qu'il est et c'est pour ça que nous
la france donc le ministère des
situation qui donne un mouvement
national nous faisons une proposition
simple puisque nous rentrons dans une
période de campagne électorale
nous proposons que ce débat des
retraites fasse l'objet d'une grande
consultation nationale et que les
décisions ne soient prises que par le
prochain président la république que ce
soit celui actuel qui se succéderaient
lui-même ou bien une présidente un
président et je pense que ça changerait
beaucoup de choses que les français
aient toutes les informations et en
particulier et à décider sur les trois
problèmes majeurs
doit-on allonger l'âge de la retraite
doit-on changer le niveau de la pension
ou doit-on contribuer plus tout au long
de sa vie voilà vers quoi on pourrait
aller avec une consultation nationale
qui serait donc faite lors du prochain
mandat présidentiel
mais vous le voyez il y a un réel
blocage est ce que vous avez entendu ce
qu'ont dit les responsables syndicaux
un responsable syndical s'est rendu donc
au palais présidentiel en disant nous ne
voulons pas de réformes dans ce mandat
pas plus que dans le prochain on voit
très bien que les syndicats qu'il
représente à peine 8% des personnes en
activité compte bloqué le système
donc à part peut-être certains avec un
esprit plus d'ouverture comme on peut
saluer notamment l'attitude de monsieur
laurent berger voilà donc je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention
70% d'abstention non récentes élections
locales des syndicats qui ne
représentent que 8% il faut faire
attention que ce ne soit pas les
personnes les moins représentative qui
prennent les décisions
alors avant de vous faire réagir les
concessions va écouter les monsieur oui
on va juste pardonnez moi vous allez
pouvoir répondre à stéphane pelé mais il
ya quand même un syndicat évidemment
c'est peut-être pas celui auquel vous
faisiez référence qui est d'accord avec
l'opportunité d'une réforme est
évidemment c'est le medef je vous
propose d'écouter un geoffroy roux de
bézieux nous mais favorable à une
réforme des retraites qu'ils soient qui
traîne la seule mesure qui soit vraiment
significatif qui est la mesure d'âge
donc le passage de l'âge légal de 62 à
63 64 65
mais on s'interroge sur le bon timing
surtout avec le variant belta et la
recrudescence est président du medef qui
s'interroge quand même lui aussi sur le
timing mais voilà qui dit en gros le
passage de l'âge légal de 62 à 63 64
voire 65 et est inéluctable pour lui
yves contassot on imagine que vous
partagez pas cet avis il n'empêche c'est
vrai que par rapport au reste de
l'europe la france serait en contraste
oui alors monsieur roux de bézieux ne
manque pas d'air quant au voile et
parachutes dorés que tous ces grands
patrons s'attribuent à coups de millions
de millions payés sur le dos des
entreprises
venir dire que les salariés doivent
travailler plus longtemps c'est vraiment
d'un cynisme et d'un mais aussi les
entreprises
vous voulez qu'on regarde les
répartition des revenus en france entre
les patrons notamment des grandes
entreprises mais pas que et puis les
salariés on peut s'amuser à ça mais je
peux vous garantir le medef ne sortira
pas grandie et alors pourquoi
pousse-t-il évidemment à ça mais qu'ils
commencent par regard 50 % des personnes
de plus de 60 ans ne travaille pas ne
travaille pas il n'y a pas d'emploi pour
les seniors
et on va leur dire alors déjà vous
n'avez pas d'emploi mais vous allez
attendre deux ans de plus pour toucher
la retraite c'est ça l'amélioration de
la situation
si vous voulez avoir à nouveau alors des
gilet jaune de puissance 10
continuons comme ça c'est vraiment de la
provocation
et si monsieur roux de bézieux dit dans
le deuxième quinquennat ou prochain
quinquennat c'est pas par hasard c'est
que il sait très bien que ce n'est pas
acceptable socialement et que dans la
situation économique délicate que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec ce risque
en plus le quatrième vague il n'a aucune
envie qui est le feu sur le plan social
à la rentrée
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils demandent le
report en espérant qu'après avril 2022
ça ira mieux et qu'il pourra passer en
force alors monsieur collègues quand on
dit les syndicats qui représentent 8%
monsieur macron il a fait vingt et un
peu plus de 20% à la présidentielle donc
dire que c'est plus démocratique quand
on a fait 20 % que 8%
j'en suis pas convaincu moi je pense
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir un
grand nenê je propose justement que les
français se déterminent sur cette
réforme majeure les questions préférées
2 6 1 6 0 4 0 et d'ailleurs pour
employer une formule de notre présidente
aurélie gros je vous dirais on ne
gouverne pas contre son peuple
pas plus le président que les syndicats
et je pense qu'il faudra rendre la
parole aux français dans ce type de
réformes et un nom de consultation de
concertation puis ensuite un système
soit référendaire peut-être vous n'y
serait pas favorable mais en tous les
cas un système qui fait que le président
nouvellement élu aurait toute légitimité
cette fois ci pour mener cette réforme
voilà vous pouvez donner aux citoyennes
on a vu qu'on tient une conférence
citoyenne que les citoyens ont la parole
que fait le gouvernement il s'assoit
dessus complètement donc pourquoi demain
prendrait-il des décisions ou fixer
l'âge est lui bien en tire par avance
qu'il n'écoutera pas les conclusions
merci en tout cas à tous les déesses je
ne le crois pas ça je ne le crois pas ni
merci moi que oui et vous allez voir que
la citoyenneté va rester l'acte fort des
mandats à venir une citoyenneté partagée
merci beaucoup stéphane olive contassot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct pour
celui ci est là sans direction rt france
et l'exécutif qui n'entend pas donc un
dramatiser autour de ce dossier explosif
des retraites pourtant les syndicats
on en a parlé à l'instant ne veulent pas
entendre parler sous peine mobilisation
à la rentrée pour en parler on retrouve
alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous alors clore la séquence
en sur les retraites a un petit peu
l'ambition d' emmanuel macron même s'ils
ne se prononce pas encore clairement sur
le sujet quand on voit que même la cdt
menacent de faire grève à la rentrée on
se dit que cette affaire risque de
mettre du monde dans la rue évidemment
elle a déjà mis beaucoup de monde dans
la rue alors de la première mouture il a
fallu utiliser le 49-3 rappelez-vous le
premier conseil sanitaire a été réservé
et finalement au 49 3 pour faire passer
cette réforme des retraites au forceps
avec tous ces français tous les
partenaires sociaux dans la rue vent
debout contre cette réforme
rien n'a changé à la crise sanitaire est
passée par là et c'est encore pire parce
que on se demande pourquoi vouloir à
tout prix remettre cette réforme sur le
tapis alors qu' il y à bien d'autres
choses à faire notamment aller chercher
la reprise économique à ce que dit bruno
le maire cherchait ses 5 % de croissance
faire en sorte d'éviter l'entrée dans la
précarité de centaines de milliers de
français
avec la réforme de l'assurance chômage
ce qui là encore n'est pas forcément le
bon moment c'est ce qu'a dit le conseil
d'état d'ailleurs et on al impression qu
emmanuel macron lui suit une feuille de
route qui n'est pas du tout celle du
peuple ou même des partenaires sociaux
et qui est simplement de dire je dois
faire ces réformes parce que sans ça je
serai sanctionné alors pas pas forcément
les urnes puisque visiblement ça n'a pas
l'air de l'inquiéter mais peut-être par
l'union européenne qui demande des
réformes structurelles pour avoir ces
aides
à la relance ce plan de quelques
milliards dead qui est conditionnée aux
réformes structurelles
alors aujourd'hui on se demande pourquoi
vouloir à tout prix remettre cette
réforme sur le tapis alors que le diable
comme je le disais d'autres sujets
importants et je pense que là emmanuel
macron pense il est capable de faire
passer tout et n'importe quoi dans ces
derniers mois en disant qu'il est
heureuse
il ne doit pas porter le flanc à la
critique en fait parce qu'il s'est vendu
comme ce grand président réformateur qui
changerait la france enkysté dans la
possibilité des réformes et lui son but
c'était de casser les corps
intermédiaires les corps d'état il l'a
fait avec la réforme de l'ena et donc
s'ils arrêtent en cours de route il
pourrait être bien sûr attaqué par un
candidat de droite comme avait bertrand
ou n'importe lequel qui sortira d'une
primaire et l'air ou autres qui dira que
ce président a encore menti et a été
incapable de réformer le pays donc je
crois que une d un des objectifs est
évidemment de merrimack rond c'est cet
objectif là justement alexis
j'y venais 1 quoi qu'il en soit quoi
qu'il en coûte
on a l'impression que emmanuel macron ce
piège lui-même soit il ne fait rien il
sera accusé de ne rien faire et de ne
pas avoir tenu ses promesses soit il
fait effectivement avec le risque social
et peut-être la perte d'une élection
derrière et évidemment on a l'impression
que pour lui c'est perdant-perdant ou
alors c'est un énième coup de poker
comme on l'a vu et mais les coups de
poker tout au long de ce quinquennat
aujourd'hui ne pas réformer et ne pas
aller au bout un de ses promesses comme
il l'avait fait ce serait évidemment
prêter le flanc à la critique d'un
président incapable encore un roi
fainéant il y en a eu beaucoup
et donc un candidat de droite arrivera
en disant allez enfin nous allons la
faire cette réforme et ce ne sera pas
mon imac rond qui la fera et puis il ya
aussi la manière stratégique de faire
des macarons qui dit écoutez peut-être
que je la remets aujourd'hui sur la
table pour que nous négocions pendant
des mois les mois qu'il me reste dans
mon mandat et nous ferons cette réforme
si je suis réélu et là à ce moment là il
serait capable de couper l'herbe sous le
pied des candidats de droite en faisant
voter pour moi comme ça cette réforme
sera fait avec le temps de la
concertation nécessaire et l'état de la
relance on verra à ce moment-là en 2022
quel sera l'état de l'économie française
donc dans tous les cas ça peut être un
coup de poker qui serait gagnant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que tous les
grands partis sont divisés n'ont pas
encore de champion avérée de programmes
clairs
or emmanuel macron lui peut dérouler ce
programme clair finir les réformes
continuent et le mandat qui lui a été
donné même si ce n'est pas un mandat
grandement majoritaire à elle était très
mal élu en 2017 il pourrait être très
mal élu en 2022 et continuer ce travail
de réforme du pays alors que d'autres
voudraient le faire à sa place donc
c'est peut-être une façon aussi de
continuer en disant que je dois faire
des choses difficiles
nous verrons si jamais la contestation
est trop lourde alors il laissera
peut-être sa place à quelqu'un comme
edouard philippe ou un autre qui prendra
alors le flambeau de ce qu'il restera de
la république en marche un parti bien
mal en point alors à 12 mois - 12 -
surtout des présidentielles finalement
lexical président réussi à faire ce type
de réforme d'importance
on est vraiment à moins de 12 mois on
est la même à dix mois huit mois
personne aucun président ne peut
réformer dans ce temps là d'autant plus
que ml macron va être le président qui
va hériter de la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne du conseil européen à
partir de janvier donc là l'agenda sera
totalement européens ce qui lui
permettra de dérouler sa communication
pro européenne avec ses partenaires du
groupe du groupe renaissance aux
personnes au parlement européen donc il
lui reste en réalité même pas six mois
la moitié d'une année alors même que les
ministères vont être empêtré dans des
difficultés qu'elle soit sociale avec en
fonction de la crise de la contestation
de la hauteur de la contestation une
relance économique qui pourrait tarder à
arriver des risques sur la relance des
risques aussi de chailly nombreuses donc
de contestation là on est vraiment dans
ce volontarisme typique des malades
mâcon qui veut toujours dire je vais le
faire je dois être en marche parce que
si je m'arrête alors c'est la fin de
tout puisque la promesse d'en marche
celle de tout le temps être en mouvement
peu importe où on va même si c'est dans
le mur
il faut y aller donc il va y aller il
verra et à chaque fois il a su
improviser regarder la crise des gilets
jaunes il a volé la parole des gilets
jaunes qui demandait un grand débat
citoyen il a fait ce grand débat où il a
monopolisé la parole
donc il pourrait tout à fait utiliser
encore des des techniques de
communication comme il a su le faire
pour lancer cette réforme des retraites
qui n'en sera pas une
et puis dérouler son programme avec la
présidence de l'union européenne à
partir de janvier
mais c'est sûr que dans les ministères
dès à présent tout le monde qui est
encore dans les cabinets ministériels
sont là pour faire campagne sans doute
pour la rédaction des mâles bacon du
moment qu'il va se présenter à sa
réélection mais vous restez avec nous à
lexie polak arriver un autre sujet qui a
été abordé lors de cette réunion cet
après-midi à l'elysée à savoir la
vaccination obligatoire discuter entre
eux emmanuel macron donc et et les
partenaires sociaux au moment d'ailleurs
quasiment le conseil d'état refusé de
suspendre ne pas sanitaire du fait qu'il
ne s'applique pas aux activités dites du
quotidien le gouvernement lui multiplie
les pistes pour inciter à la vaccination
hélène masquelier
trouver le bon dosage c'est le
casse-tête actuelle du gouvernement pour
accroître la campagne de vaccination
convaincre contraindre ou inciter
matignon jongle entre les termes et
multiplie les arguments avec en première
ligne
celui de l'urgence nous devons aller
encore plus vite
c'est une course contre la montre qui se
joue dans notre pays le ton alarmiste
reprend avec la progression rapide du
variant delta et la menace d'une
quatrième vague alors que le rythme des
doses injectées diminue la question de
la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants se pose
seuls 57% d'entre eux sont vaccinés dans
les ehpad 64% à l'hôpital une
proposition à laquelle divers
représentants se disent favorables à
l'instar du medef peut pas exclure de
rendre la vaccination obligatoire pour
certaines professions donc les soignants
au sens large du terme compris ceux en
ehpad mais aussi dans certains cas à
l'accueil du public
quand par exemple on demande le pass
sanitaire donc le vaccin pour assister à
tel ou tel spectacle et que les salariés
qui sont qui travaillent là ne sont pas
vaccinés ça pose un problème puisque
évidemment l'impact sanitaire est pas et
pas atteint
et puis plus largement essayer de faire
en sorte que le fait d'être vacciné
procure un sont davantage pas de
vaccination obligatoire pour tous pour
le moment affirme le gouvernement qui
mise davantage sur l'incitation avec
différentes pistes envisagées on peut
imaginer que le périmètre du passani
terre puisse évoluer qu'il puisse
concerner davantage d'activités et que à
un moment donné la question de la
gratuité des tests leur prise en charge
par la sécurité sociale se pose ce qui
peut être une incitation à se faire
vacciner davantage la france
s'inspirerait du modèle israélien avec
une preuve de vaccination obligatoire
pour se rendre au restaurant à la
piscine ou aller à la salle de sports
problème le conseil d'état ce mardi a
refusé de suspendre le pass sanitaires
argan justement qu'il ne porte pas
atteinte à la vie privée
n'étant pas appliquée aux activités du
quotidien
à ce jour un peu plus de la moitié de la
population a reçu une injection et seul
un tiers est complètement vaccinés
le gouvernement continue de marcher sur
des oeufs pour convaincre ou contraindre
les récalcitrants jusqu'à mettre en
garde contre une possible fracture
vaccinale dans l'hexagone susceptible de
provoquer du ressentiment chez les
personnes vaccinées à un autre épisode
de la crise sanitaire s'ajouterait alors
un risque de fracture sociale et alexis
poulain qui est resté avec nous on vous
retrouve alexis un juge des référés qui
relèvent donc que ce pass sanitaire
n'est pas requis pour les activités du
quotidien ou l'exercice de certaines
libertés fondamentales voilà qui ne va
pas arranger les affaires du
gouvernement qui aimerait bien trouver
un moyen de contraindre à la vaccination
sans la force et est évidemment
aujourd'hui on voit bien que tout est
sur la table pour contraindre on
voudrait d'abord demandé aux soignants
de ce vaccin et le rendre obligatoire à
partir du moment où on va demander aux
soignants il va falloir demander à tous
les métiers de compet demandons aux
policiers demandons alors aussi aux
professeurs demandons à tous ceux qui
sont dans les métiers de contact et
alors là on va voir comment ça va se
passer parce que je crois que déjà chez
les soignants
il ya une certaine seconde 1 de soyaux
qui refusent ce vaccin qu'il juge soit
peu efficaces ou qui attendent qu'il
fasse ses preuves donc il ya là un vrai
problème sur comment faire pour que les
gens de l'accident alors il ya des tas
sanitaire empêcher finalement des
français d'avoir les mêmes droits que
les autres
et là c'est une rupture
constitutionnelle c'est la fin de
l'égalité entre tous les citoyens et je
ne crois pas que ce soit quelque chose
d'acceptable parce que on va se
retrouver avec un vrai grave problème de
rupture de l'égalité au sein de notre
pays et c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas tolérable dans la constitution le
conseil d'état pourrait alors en faire
son état et puis enfin la troisième
chose c'est pourquoi vouloir mettre un
pass sanitaires à tout prix alors que
regarder ce qu'il s'est passé à la foire
de tours exposants comme les gens qui
voulaient y aller on simplement dit nous
n'irons pas ton qui vient pas sanitaires
alors on a fait comme si ce n'était pas
nécessaire on a dit tant pis on va
laisser retomber le l'important c'est
que les gens se retrouvent alors venez
de l'autre côté de la manche à côté de
chez nous la grande bretagne un pays
massivement vaccinés ou le delta a
repris et boris johnson a pourtant dit
que le pass sanitaires à l'aide
totalement abandonné tout comme
l'utilisation des basques qui sera mon
obligatoire et à l'appréciation de
chacun donc il suffit de regarder un peu
autour ce qu'il se passe et de voir que
non la route n'est pas forcément celle
de la contrainte celle du pass celle de
l'interdiction celle de lois
liberticides de mesures liberticides
il est possible de faire autrement et
puis il est aussi question maintenant de
voir comment les vaccins se comporte
face à ces nombreux variant un delta
epsilon peu importe les noms qui vont
arriver
est-ce qu'ils vont être efficace est ce
qu'il va falloir de nouveau vaccin dans
les mois qui viennent comment tout ça
peut-être gérer je ne crois pas que
c'est en contraignant en montant une
partie de la population contre l'autre
qu'on va gérer cette crise sanitaire qui
depuis le début rappelons le a été gérée
comme une crise sécuritaire et de
manière extrêmement liberticide
rappelons-nous les autorisations auto
signé de sortie les rues qui étaient
plus ou moins interdite de masques ou
non il ya eu tous les sons contraire
depuis mars 2020 et on continue dans ce
grand n'importe quoi dans ce grand
déballage d'inventivité liberticides au
lieu finalement d'essayer de faire corps
de dire aux gens attention lire un truc
qui marche peut-être c'est les gestes
barrières les vaccins sans doute aide à
réduire la contamination
maintenant pourquoi vouloir à tout prix
forcez les gens qui ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner alors que c'est tout à
fait leur droit rompre ça je crois que
ça va compliquer beaucoup les choses
et peu importe la course qui est fait
entre variant et vaccins aujourd'hui le
gouvernement joue une partition
extrêmement délicate parce que derrière
c'est encore de la contestation sociale
et c'est encore un risque de davantage
de crise au delà de la crise sanitaire
merci beaucoup avec six poulains d'avoir
été avec nous
donc quelques instants nous partirons
aux états unis le jour de l'indépendance
les dauphins transparent a été marqué de
nombreuses violences à chicago 14
personnes ont été tuées et 67 autres
blessés et puis nous parlerons du
camouflet pour le premier ministre
naftali bennet en israël pour la
première fois depuis 2003 une loi
empêchant les palestiniens mariés à des
arabes palestiniens d'obtenir la
nationalité israélienne n'a pas été
reconduite par le pardon
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses les chiffres qui sont
avancés qui sont montrés aux salariés et
à leurs représentants sont des chiffres
en décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise c'est fiable
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents ce point
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire qu'un autre le
peuple c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les numéros uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour l
assister à une guerre dans l'est oui la
guerre est possible il ya de multiples
façons de l'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
20h35 soit idée bienvenue en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez que se
passe-t-il à chicago le week-end de la
fête nationale américaine a été l'un des
plus sanglants pour la ville de
l'illinois qui a déploré de nombreux
actes de violences par armes à feu
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter thomas bonnet en
direct de washington bonsoir thomas un
week end très meurtrier qui vient
alimenter des statistiques alarmantes
oui c'est malheureusement assez habituel
qu'il y ait une hausse du nombre de
victimes par arme à feu le week-end de
la fête nationale américaine mais c'est
vrai que cette année les statistiques
sont particulièrement alarmante
particulièrement tragique avec une
recrudescence des tirs par arme à feu
alors il ya un site qui s'appelle gun
violens arxiv qui tente de recenser le
nombre de tirs par arme à feu le nombre
de victimes pour l'ensemble de ce
week-end selon leurs estimations qui
sont encore provisoires
au moins 150 personnes sont décédées
lors de 400 fusillade qui ont eu lieu
rien que ce week-end sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain
vous est pris l'exemple de deux villes
qui ont été particulièrement touchés
d'abord la ville de philadelphie qui
avait un rassemblement une foule qui
était massée pour observer les feux
d'artifices pour cette fête nationale
américaine
à ce moment là un tireur ou plusieurs
tireurs on ne sait pas encore tout à
fait les circonstances de cet acte ils
ont tiré donc sans munitions en
direction de cette foule ça a tué deux
jeunes personnes deux jeunes hommes et
une fille de 16 ans a été sérieusement
blessée dans la ville de cela défie
depuis le début de l'année on est déjà à
281 homicide
c'est une augmentation de 37% par
rapport à l'année 2020 une année 2020
qui était déjà record pour justement le
nombre d'homicides dans la ville autre
exemple vous avez déjà un petit peu
parlé c'est la ville de chicago 104
personnes ont été victimes de tirs par
arme à feu ce week end
dix neuf personnes au moins sont décédés
13 enfants ont été blessés et là encore
dans cette ville les statistiques sont
assez alarmante puisque depuis le début
de l'année on est déjà à 2
mille fusillade dans la ville de chicago
est thomas quelle est la position du
gouvernement américain sur ce sujet
alors il n'y a pas eu de réaction
officielle pour le moment de la part des
autorités que ce soit de joe biden ou de
sa porte parole qui s'est exprimé dans
le courant de la journée pour l'instant
pas de prise de parole publique sur ce
sujet mais on sait que joe biden a fait
de la lutte contre la circulation des
armes à feu un des ses priorités de son
mandat il a annoncé un plan le 24 juin
dernier pour tenter d'une part de
limiter le type d'armes qui peut être
acheté aussi pour renforcer le contrôle
du profil des potentiels acheteurs
d'armes à feu et puis il veut aussi
s'attaquer au marché parallèle il a
annoncé le déploiement de cinq unités
spéciales dans cinq villes des états
unis dont la ville de chicago parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre que malgré
ces chiffres très important de victimes
par arme à feu dans la ville de chicago
on ne peut pas dans cette ville acheter
une arme dans un magasin il s'agit donc
essentiellement d'armes issues du marché
parallèle alors ce plan de joe biden se
heurte au blocage parlementaire de la
part des élus d'opposition les élus
républicains et xambox vous savez le
fameux second amendement de la
constitution américaine qui stipule que
les américains ont le droit de porter
une arme
et puis pour les élus républicains la
cause du nombre de cette augmentation du
nombre de victimes par arme à feu et
finalement le laxisme d'un certain
nombre d'élus démocrates
évidemment la maire de chicago qui est
donc une mère démocrate est très
régulièrement la victime de critiques de
la part des élus républicains qui
accusent notamment vous savez ce
mouvement qui lors des manifestations
qui ont eu lieu l'an passé appelé à
démanteler une partie de la police en
coupant certain nombre de financements
alors s'il n'y a pas d'entente sur les
causes de cette augmentation du nombre
d'homicides en tout cas il ya un constat
c'est que c'est en nette augmentation
2020 a été une année record par rapport
au nombre de victimes par arme à feu joe
biden parle même d'une épidémie de
violence avec ses armes dont qui
circulent aux états unis merci thomas
bonnet en direct de
washington disparition cette nuit d'un
avion dans la péninsule du kamtchatka
dans l'extrême orient de la russie des
morceaux d'un autonome 26 ont été
retrouvés par des secouristes à quelques
kilomètres à peine de l'aéroport où il
devait atterrir l'appareil
l'hypothèse du crash de fait plus de
doute tout comme l'espoir de retrouver
des survivants
la correspondance à moscou de vera
goffman il n'y aurait aucun survivant
dans le crash de l'avion dans l'extrême
orient russe les autorités ont confirmé
que l'avion à bord duquel se trouvaient
van deux passagers et 6 membres
d'équipage s'est écrasé lors de son
atterrissage dans la région du
kamtchatka il effectué la liaison entre
la ville de petropavlovsk kamtchatski et
la ville de pallanne à une partie du
fuselage a été retrouvé sur le versant
de la colline petit bras tca et la
seconde se trouve en mer à 4 km de la
côte
les services de secours ont fait savoir
que plusieurs bateaux et avait été
envoyé près de la zone supposée du crash
une enquête a été ouverte par les
autorités russes
il envisage plusieurs versions de
l'accident mauvaise météo
dysfonctionnements de l'avion ou erreur
de pilotage ou propose d'écouter ses
grognards aujourd'hui l'avion qui
effectuait la liaison entre
petropavlovsk-kamtchatski est pas la
nasse est écrasé le drame s'est produit
lors de la proche vraisemblablement
quand l'avion effectué sa deuxième
manoeuvre en raison de la mauvaise
visibilité actuellement grâce à une
opération de sauvetage à grande échelle
qui a été lancé avec la participation de
l'aviation du territoire kamtchatka et
de celle du ministère des situations
d'urgence du ministère de la défense
les débris de l'avion aurait été
retrouvé à cinq kilomètres au nord de
pallanne à le fuselage se trouve sur le
littoral
la partie principale de l'avion et dans
la zone côtière
actuellement les services au sol se
déplace vers le site afin de confirmer
qu'il s'agit bien de l'avion recherché
dans un communiqué de presse l' agence
fédérale de transport aérien a fait
savoir que les conditions
météorologiques ont été particulièrement
difficiles au moment de l'atterrissage
de l'appareil
elle a évoqué un brouillard de nuages
fragmenté et des nuages continuent à une
altitude de 720 m les colonies
israéliennes dans le viseur du plus gros
fonds de pension norvégien klp annonce
se désengager de 16 entreprises
présentes dans les colonies israéliennes
en cisjordanie
parmi elles figurent deux françaises
altice et alstom pour cause de violation
du droit international
david khalifa s'engager pour les droits
humains au péril de bénéfices attractif
c'est le pari osé fait par klp considéré
comme le plus gros fonds de pension
norvégien avec 80 milliards d'euros
d'actifs klp vont ses parts dans
plusieurs entreprises internationales
pour leur implication dans les colonies
israéliennes en cisjordanie
au total cela concerne cette société
dont les français alstom et altice
alstom multinationale spécialisée dans
les transports est accusé d'avoir
participé financièrement à la
construction de bâtiments et
d'infrastructures des territoires
occupés par les israéliens en
cisjordanie
altis de son côté groupe télécoms
appartenant au milliardaire
franco-israélien patrick drahi est elle
accusée par le fonds norvégien d'avoir
participé à la transformation des
territoires en zone résidentielle
attractive en y offrant leurs services
le géant américain motorola a fait
également partie de cette liste visé par
cas elle paie pour avoir fourni un
logiciel de vidéo surveillance et de
commandement permettant de contrôler les
frontières entre territoires israéliens
et palestiniens
les entreprises ont la responsabilité de
respecter protéger les droits humains
dans tous les pays où elle opère
indépendamment du respect de ses droits
par l'état lui-même
nous avons des attentes et des principes
clairs en tant qu'investisseur
responsable
alors évidemment cet acte n'est pas le
fruit du hasard il s'inscrit dans la
logique des nations unies souvenez-vous
nous sommes en février 2020 l'onu publie
une liste
112 sociétés internationales des
entreprises ayant des activités dans ces
colonies israéliennes considérées comme
illégales au regard du droit
international et ces sociétés ne sont
pas des moindres on y retrouve airbnb
expédia tripadvisor booking ou encore
opodo tous des célèbres sites internet
de location ou de tourisme des banques
pour la majorité d'entre elles
israélienne ils figurent également des
banques qui sont parfois financés
directement par des banques françaises
hillier fayard membres de france
palestine solidarité présents sur notre
plateau lors de la publication de cette
liste avait dénoncé ses agissements
l'objectif numéro un c'est de demander
aux entreprises de respecter le droit
international de respecter les droits de
l'homme
en fait dans une région que ces droits
de l'homme sont bafoués
les cci sera liège ici il ya beaucoup de
banques à la dizaine de grandes banques
israéliennes qui sont présentes
l'objectif maintenant ça va être de
faire aussi que les banques françaises
est une société d'assurance axa de
financement ses banques israéliennes
parce que en finançant les banques
israéliennes et financé indirectement la
pologne en 2020 cette liste noire a
qualifié de honteuse par israël mehdi
gantz alors leader de la liste centriste
bleu blanc à cette époque parle le jour
sombre pour les droits de l'homme
le ministère des affaires étrangères
dénonce lui une pression politique
destinés à causer du tort à israël un an
et demi plus tard les conséquences
commencent seulement à faire effet klp a
voulu frapper fort puisque lé des
investissements du fonds norvégien
s'élève à environ 30 millions d'euros et
elle n'est pas la seule à suivre cette
initiative en mai dernier le fonds
souverain de la norvège qui représente
près de 1100 milliards d'euros d'actifs
a exclu deux groupes israéliens
impliqués dans le développement de
colonies israéliennes en cisjordanie en
violation du droit international d
action saluée par la palestine et qui
confirme les craintes initiales de
l'état hébreu lors de la sortie de cette
liste et craignant qu'elle ne serve de
base à de futures boycott nous y sommes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
myriam
la politologue spécialiste du
moyen-orient bonsoir mairie avait trahi
merci d'être avec nous ce désengagement
du fonds de pension norvégien klp c'est
clairement un acte politique
oui c'est un acte politique d'abord qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte particulier
puis quand on sort d'une nouvelle dans
un nouveau cycle de violences entre
israéliens et palestiniens il faut pas
oublier que tout ça est encore frais la
dernière flambée flambée de violence qui
a été d'ailleurs particulièrement mais
vite et puis surtout c'est à un acte
politique en ce qu'il réaffirme le droit
international qui depuis de nos amis et
mis de côté par les israéliens mais
aussi par une partie de la communauté
internationale qui s'est rangée du côté
du côté des termes israéliens tel est le
cas notamment de l'administration trump
lorsque l'ambassade des états unis a été
de transférer à jérusalem est qui
s'appelle à l'acte de reconnaissance
implicite de 2 du statut de capitale
d'israël accordé par 39 administration à
jérusalem alors que jérusalem reste au
coeur du conflit et des tensions on l'a
vu très récemment et donc voilà je le
dirai qu effectivement c'est un peu
peut-être inattendu mais les acteurs
économiques font aussi la politique dans
cette région et donc il faut le voir
sous cet angle double alors le font
expliqué que cette présence dans les
colonies israéliennes en cisjordanie
contribuer à une violation du droit
humain international au sein des
territoires occupés en quoi est ce le
cas alors il yad'abord violation par le
col et ryan compte illégales au regard
du droit international elles constituent
une occupation dans des territoires
puis ils n'appartiennent pas à l'ehpad
pour elle
et puis surtout le fonds de pension
norvégien accusait des push it et comme
la société de monsieur drive et la
fougue et talent femmes pour le cal de
rendre justement territoire attractif
pour les colons qui ont rappelons le
sont enduits logique de brantes israël
général mental
dans ces territoires pour deux raisons
soit de réforme religieuse parce qu'on
parle de juifs orthodoxes il ya peu
frais territoire des tueries ne dure qui
verrait territoire a par contre elle il
serait le directory les geeks et puis
deuxième chose il faut quand même dire
une crise du logement en panne depuis
deux longues danic qui fait tiquer
territoire sont attractifs pour des gens
qui cherchent des logements des vitres
l1 qui cherchent des logements à bas
prix et donc évidemment c'est un
argument fort qui a permis au
gouvernement l'état n'est notamment avec
évidemment l'appui de l'extrême droite
israélienne d'appuyer les
délocalisations et colony donne en
territoire palestinien et tout cela bien
sûr créer une situation explosive
donc y'a quand même la volonté à mon
avis je crois d'ailleurs peu d'effets
faut être réaliste il ya quand même la
volonté de la firme et encore une fois
le droit international et le fait que
qu'il faut parvenir à une position en
dehors de cette escalade en tout cas se
font à quelle paix n'en est pas à son
premier coup d'essai un et c'était déjà
désengagé du plus grand opérateur
multiports indien pour son implication
dans un projet de l'armée birmane
on a clairement l'impression quand on
voit ce genre de choses que
certaines entreprises certains privés en
tout cas sont plus audacieux que les
états eux-mêmes pour peser dans ce genre
de situations qu'ils estiment inégale en
tout cas où il ya les violations de
droits oui plus aux dates sur la
dépendance a quand même un personnage
actionnaires donc quand même à mon avis
la d'être bien positif à un diurétique
personnes il sans doute d'ailleurs a
fait face avec l'opposition autant
d'amis du fonds de pension parce que je
pense parce qu'il ya un bloc est clair
que nous entendu une poignée de
personnes qui ont voulu faire un geste
les politiques forts bon il est vrai que
il faut avouer tension contrairement à
l'état mais pas puis à des obligations
diplomatiques
il explique aussi pourquoi il est très
difficile aujourd'hui pour qu'on était
international et pour les états puis un
des relations bilatérales avec israël
est très difficile d'influencé israël
layali pression économique qui est très
concrète
il va avoir un impact et est perçu comme
étant le seul moyen de faire plier les
israéliens sur un certain nombre de
conditions qu'ils veulent imposer encore
une fois merci meriem meinrath vous
propose de rester avec nous car on va
évoquer ensemble un autre au sujet
puisque à jérusalem le nouveau
gouvernement israélien essuyé son
premier revers au parlement le parti au
pouvoir de nefta ni bennett a perdu le
vote sur l'extension de la loi sur la
citoyenneté et litigieuses cette fois
controversée instaurée en 2003 interdit
la citoyenneté ou la résidence
permanente aux palestiniens des
territoires occupés son épouse et des
palestiniens le des israéliens en pardon
le vote n'ayant pas atteint la majorité
avec 59 voix pour 59 points contre il a
été rejetée le premier ministre a
fustigé le résultat certains membres de
son propre parti rpt ont voté contre
vous propose de l'écouter
ce soir l'opposition a délibérément
porté un coup direct à la sécurité de
l'état par amertume et frustration ils
finissent par nuire à ce qui est le
mieux pour le pays
ceux qui ont voté contre la loi sur la
citoyenneté de bibi à tibi et jusqu'à
chikli ont choisi la petite politique
plutôt que ce qui est le mieux pour les
citoyens d'israël et maintenant pendant
longtemps ils devront justifier leurs
actes auprès des citoyens d'israël d'un
politologue spécialiste du moyen-orient
vous êtes resté avec nous c'est donc un
premier revers un pont pour le premier
ministre
naftali bennett avec on le rappelle un
des gens qui ont voté de son propre camp
contre ça dit quoi une coédition
définitivement très fragile alors fait
une coalition fragile parce que très
hétéroclite
il faut quand même savoir que la
coalition formée par naftali bennet
comprend des parties finalement on
n'attendrait pas là les partis d'extrême
gauche notamment et puis ya bien sûr les
islamistes
les partis flamands jeu côté palestinien
même si a quand même en étant menés
jusqu'au boutisme idéologique ces partis
qui explique pourquoi même
paradoxalement ils leur rapprochement
maintenant en face à lui très puissant
hulk ou de lui même sans la fusion de
netanyahu qui conserve son aspect
historique
mais surtout ce que ça traduit et
lampard dans le débat qui est déjà très
vieille fille qui porte sur l'identité
mistral parce que souvenez vous il ya
quelques années les uhlans un débat très
vif à la concept sur la question
identité juive d'israël
et c'est là qu'on a vu le virer kantisme
de la droite dure qui est aujourd'hui au
pouvoir alors et pouvoir encore une fois
parce que il ya un certain de
circonstances qui ont permis de séduire
tricorps notamment l'usure de netanyahou
il est bon il faut quand même bien une
chose dont on parle de revers certes
mais
ce gouvernement sur cette question à
l'appui d'une partie très importante de
l'opinion publique
aliens encore une fois parce qu'on sort
d'un nouveau stick des violences qui a
créé très très grande méfiance à l'égard
des pays bien d'où l'argument défendu
par bennett que d'accorder la
nationalité israélienne à des
palestiniens et par simple mais pour
l'instant le motif d' alliance de
mariage avec des arabes israéliens
constituent une menace envers la
sécurité d'israël
il avait quand même un boulevard
contextuelle pour à passer cet argument
qui est celui d'une partie des litres
elle n'a aujourd'hui il faut être clair
merci merci et médiamat veine d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
doit-on craindre une quatrième vague de
contaminations en france ne variant
delta plus gagnent du terrain dans
l'hexagone est inquiété spécialistes et
puis nous vous livrons pourquoi avec le
généticien philippe froguel puis
direction la tunisie où l'afflux de
patients continuent dans les hôpitaux
qui sont débordés
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution un
supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
prix puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement chinois en l'état actuel
des capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terres rares il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes nous
bouleverse nous bouleverse toujours
savait pas ce qu'on les comprend pas il
nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à rome alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous craignent
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
tout est pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le grès tic est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric site c'est par le président
c'est la bureaucratie du brics comment
ça va se passer par exemple pour l'été
qui arrive la côte d'azur verra peu ou
pas d'anglais je suspecte effectivement
le gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
[Musique]
et
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues qui avait
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
font normalement les cellules sensibles
à la lumière dans la rétine pas ce qu'il
va dire qu'il voit un pc il distingue la
lumière il distingue quoi exactement par
le patient et que le pain par exemple de
reconnaître les passages protégés dans
la rue de détecter des objets différents
objets de petite taille de grande taille
plusieurs niveaux central de les compter
de les attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est finalement pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 6 juillet si le variant
delta gagne du terrain en france et fait
craindre une nouvelle vague d'autres
sont également en embuscade longue date
par exemple c'est son nom découverts en
amérique du sud serait plus contagieux
et plus résistants aux vaccins classé
comme variant d'intérêt et par l'om est
ce qu'il serait déjà présent dans pas
moins de 27 pays d'europe
une longue réunion d' écoute mais pas de
décision ce stade et organisations
syndicales et patronales étaient reçus
par emmanuel macron ce mardi sur la
table le dossier explosif de la réforme
des retraites que l'exécutif n'entend
pas dramatiser au menu également la
lutte contre les inégalités économiques
et la relance post qu'ovide deux ans
prennent incendie de notre dame une
nouvelle plainte doit être déposée en
justice pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui la cgt paris l'association
henri pézerat et deux familles d'enfants
exposés au plomb après l'incendié de la
cathédrale dénonce de graves négligences
de la part des autorités
le parvis est à nouveau fermé au public
depuis le
lui mais la découverte de niveaux de
concentrations très élevées
[Musique]
et on à l'aube d'une quatrième vague
causée par un énième variant au fil des
dernières semaines de nouvelles formes
de co vides sont apparus faisant
craindre un rebond épidémique avec
davantage de contamination retour sur un
an et demi de mutation avec maxime abers
alfacam à epsilon l'omda delta la liste
des variants du coc vide semble
s'allonger avec le temps car pour un
virus
la mutation est le seul moyen de survie
ces évolutions lui permettent de passer
plus facilement d'un humain à un autre
ou d'échapper à la réponse immunitaire
et plus les virus circulent plus il mute
et s'adapte dans le cas du coc vie de 19
en novembre 2020 les scientifiques
avaient déjà détecté une douzaine de
milliers de mutation
si la plupart sont sans conséquence
certaines ont mis l'organisation de la
santé en alerte jusqu'à les classés en
deux catégories
d'abord les variants préoccupant ce qui
augmente la transmissibilité du coc vide
19 premiers nommés dans cette catégorie
le variant alpha apparu au royaume uni
en septembre dernier pour tromper nos
cellules celui ci utilise des mutations
sur la protéine spike
cette dernière est la cible de nos
anticorps et des vaccins actuels censée
combattre le virus
devenu très vite majoritaire cette
nouvelle souche contraint le royaume uni
à de nouvelles restrictions dont la
fermeture de ses frontières
la belgique l'italie ou encore la france
suspende leurs vols à destination de
londres
à l'époque le ministre français des
solidarités et de la santé olivier
ferrand se montrent prudents nous
faisons à la fois un séquençage
génétique
de certaines souches virales qui sont
identifiés chez des gens qui sont
positifs sur les 500 derniers séquençage
les experts m'ont dit qu'ils n'avaient
pas trouvé ce variant maintenant nous
allons continuer de chercher on va
chercher encore plus fort d'ailleurs
pour identifier si vraiment ce virus
circule si ce pari variante chacune et
pour cause le variant britannique a bien
traversé la manche au 30 juin 2021
il représente même 77% des séquençages
réalisées dans l'hexagone selon santé
publique france parmi les autres variant
préoccupant le bétail ou sud africain et
le gars m'a dit brésilien enfin dernier
venu dans cette catégorie le variant
indien ou delta si c'est quasi semblable
était plutôt rester dans leur coin à
quelques exceptions près celui ci semble
bien plus contagieux à savoir jusqu'à 40
% de plus par rapport aux variants
britannique
il devrait même devenir prédomine en
europe d'ici la fin août selon l' oms le
variant indien va prendre le dessus
il est plus transmissible que le
précédent il faudrait que 80% de la
population soit protégée soit par le
vaccin soit en ayant été malades
la difficulté avec ce variant c'est
qu'il ya tout d'abord une phase durant
laquelle on n'est pas malade mais où on
est particulièrement contagieux
problème supplémentaire une mutation de
la mutation delta a été détectée baptisé
delta plus elle serait bien plus
transmissible aurait une plus grande
capacité à s'accrocher aux cellules
pulmonaires et seraient plus résistantes
aux anticorps générés par le vaccin ou
après contamination en europe le
portugal et le royaume uni sont pour
l'instant les plus touchées santé
publique france parle de présence
sporadique en métropole avec lui cassure
53000 séquençage
en raison de sa faible proportion l'om s
class encore ce variant dans la
catégorie à suivre si ces dernières
semaines le delta fait la une d'autres
variantes d'intérêt à l'art c'est le cas
d'epsilon et de landas plus contagieux
et résistant aux vaccins selon les
premières études menées par la revue
nature
détecté pour la première fois au pérou
fin 2020 le variant lambda il serait
responsable de 80% des contaminations
il circule déjà dans une trentaine de
pays dont les états unis le royaume uni
ou l'allemagne et inquiète par c'est
cette mutation jugée inhabituelle par
l'institut de recherche singer au
royaume-uni spécialisée dans le
séquençage du génome humain premier
détecté dès mars 2020 en californie
epsilon est lui encore à l'étude
plus facilement transmissible selon les
chercheurs américains
il résistera mieux que tous ses cousins
à la double doses des vaccins fighter
biotech et modern a là encore les
données épidémiologiques sont limitées
mais une troisième dose pourrait être
nécessaire
face à cette souche plus virulente
éloignant l'idée d'une immunité
naturelle ou vaccinale et pour en parler
nous sommes avec philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 bonsoir philippe
rogué merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
l'onda epsilon différents types de deux
variantes plus ou moins inquiétant on
sourirait un des noms donnés si ce
n'était pas aussi grave on a envie de
vous poser une question toute simple la
question que tout le monde se pose quand
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
eh bien ça s'arrêtera quand on aura à
juguler cette épidémie c'est à dire que
quand tu es le virus ne circulera pas ou
presque pas et dans ce cas là
effectivement les mutations vont
diminuer ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle
s'arrêtera complètement
on a bien vu pour la grippe ou pour
certains autres virus donc ça peut
rester ce qu'on appelle l'endémique en
tout cas pour l'instant on en est loin
de ça c'est très épidémique et
et variant comme c'était prévu par
beaucoup à meinier par d'autres
s'accumulent et s'aggravent les uns les
autres
le groupe se donne donc classé à suivre
pas par l'om est ce ça veut dire quoi
concrètement comment on décide de
classer à suivre invariants et de classe
et inquiétant un autre ce n'est pas
facile
d'abord il faut le retrouver dans
plusieurs endroits en même temps il faut
avoir du séquençage notamment qui permet
de le détecter très rapidement ce qui
nous manque totalement en france
et puis ensuite il faut faire des
corrélations entre le nombre de cas avec
ce variant et puis l'a transmis de façon
de 7 soit transmise pas ce qu'on appelle
le r de transmission le taux de
transmission
et puis on regarde aussi les entrées
dans les hôpitaux on regarde les
symptômes et on regarde la mortalité
avec tout ça on compare plusieurs pays
on arrive à avoir une idée si ce variant
d'avoir ci se développe et s'il est
dangereux par exemple variant epsilon et
très dangereux mais pour l'instant il se
développe pas il ya à peu près un gain
de 5% des cas en californie donc ce
n'est pas un danger majeur fonctionne
vous parlez de séquençage 77000
séquençage en france alors que le
royaume uni en pratique et près de 600
milles depuis le temps qu'on en parle
vous êtes l'un des chantres de cette
méthode
pourquoi ce retard français persistant
ce retard est pour moi idéologique il y
à une opposition d'un certain nombre de
virologues notamment membres des
conseils scientifiques qui refuse de
penser qu'il ya autre chose que la
protéine spike et de quelques mutations
qui détecte il ya d'ailleurs très
difficilement par pcr et nous les
généticiens on pense que il faut c'est
quand c'est l'ensemble du génome parce
que le invariants lambda ypsilon et bien
c'est pas simplement de trois mutations
c'est tout un ensemble
et c'est ça que lui donnent ses
caractéristiques particulièrement
dangereuse justement ces mutations
qu'elle est la rapidité de ces mutations
du ducobu 19 ans on a le sentiment vous
allez peut être me corriger si je me
trompe que plus ça va plus les variants
se développe nombreux et rapidement
est ce que c'est vrai longuet une raison
à ça c'est que par rapport à la souche
chinoise d'origine il s'agit d'une
accumulation de mutation par exemple
peut varier anglais c'était 18 mutation
le variant 10 indiens de delta c15
mutation est en fait les premières
mutations qui sont apparus ne comprenais
rien du tout comme comme les faits et
puis progressivement il y en a certaines
qui va avoir un effet nous on appelle
synergies que c'est à dire qu'elles vont
entraîner tout un tas de
caractéristiques qui rentre dans le
virus plus contagieux voire dangereux
peut-on envisager à l'hypothèse heureuse
ailleurs d'un nombre limité de mutation
qui conduirait le le virus à une impasse
enfin ça c'est une hypothèse défendue
par de plusieurs virologue français qui
pour l'instant ne s'est pas passé il
savait si on ressemble pas à une mouche
ou un diplodocus c'est que notre génome
à à des ressources très très importante
et je dirais infinie de transformation
et donc les virus existent depuis des
milliards d'années ont montré leur
capacité à se transformer donc moi je ne
crois pas que le virus du cornât va
brutalement s'arrêter d'être imaginatif
au contraire ça va continuer voilà bon
de rassurer pas comme d'habitude mais
bon on ne vous en dit pas pour être
rassurés on veut bénéficier de votre vos
connaissances précieuses
al'inverse à ce que ça peut aller encore
plus loin et plus fort est arrivé a
vraiment eu un mutant extrêmement
dangereux encore plus meurtrier toujours
plus meurtrier est ce que c'est une
hypothèse que vous envisagez également
une hypothèse qui est toujours plausible
mais pour l'instant c'est parce qu
arrive puisque c'est ces variants
n'entraîne pas de résistance en vie
réelle compte contre les vaccins
notamment les vaccins et rennes je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la meilleure chose à
faire c'est de se faire vacciner
massivement car si on diminue la
distribution diminue aussi les capacités
de changement de mutation de ces virus
et bien entendu le risque de se
retrouver malade est encore plus de
lettres très malade à l'hôpital voire de
mourir
krainer vous justement par rapport à
cette vaccination qu'un jour un mutant
soit beaucoup plus fort et que le vaccin
n'est plus aucune efficacité
pour l'instant c'est pas ce qui est
arrivé est donc on peut espérer qu'on
aura juguler l'épidémie avant que ça
arrive mais n'oublions pas quand même
que des fabricants sont en train de
réfléchir à une deuxième voire troisième
génération de vaccins qui risque de nous
arriver pour les gens vaccinés comme moi
c'est d'avoir une troisième dose à la
fin de l'année c'est ce qui est préparé
en israël en angleterre et aux états
unis
encore faut-il que cette troisième d'eau
soit un peu transformés on permette de
résister aux variants présent et
peut-être pas me suivre
stéphane fort gagne quelque chose qu'on
entend ici ou là dans la rue évidemment
on pas par des généticiens mais quand on
dit voilà quand on voit ces vacances ces
variants qui se propage on se dit que ça
ne peut que être sorti d'un laboratoire
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ce genre
de phrases ont chois faire attention aux
discussions conspirationnistes il ya
tout un débat scientifique là dessus
comment se fait-il que
cette zone au c'est à dire cette
infection chez des animaux soient passés
à l'homme il ya encore un article
aujourd'hui là-dessus qui semble
expliquer ce qui a pu arriver
je pense personnellement que l'hypothèse
la plus probable c'est que c'est pas ce
ne soit pas un accident de laboratoire
mais que c'est une une transformation à
partir de gens qui ont manipulé manger
vendu des animaux sauvages à ce qu'il
n'aurait dû jamais dû faire
merci philippe non pas stéphane philippe
froguel à d'avoir était avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes un chercheur et
généticiens merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et on en parlait évidemment à
l'instant avec philippe froguel 1 le
vexin pour leur présenter comme seul
moyen de lutter efficacement contre
l'épidémie outre les restrictions
sanitaires bien évidemment sera-t-il
obligatoire ou non ce vaccin le ministre
de la santé olivier verrey en reçoit ce
mercredi à 17 heures des représentants
des soignants pour une consultation sur
l'obligation vaccinale en plus des
fédérations syndicales des représentants
de médecins de pharmaciens infirmiers
dentistes ou encore sages femmes
participeront à cette consultation et en
espagne à présent la catalogne qui
annonce réimposé des restrictions pour
freiner l'augmentation exponentielle des
quatre co vie d'une recrudescence qui
touche particulièrement les jeunes ont
fait le point sur la situation avec
notre correspondante à barcelone
clémentine laurent retour à la case
départ les discothèques catalan ferment
leurs portes seulement deux semaines
après leur réouverture
c'est une situation à laquelle personne
ne s'attendait ici à barcelone car
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours la
situation sanitaire se voulait plutôt
rassurantes
et pourtant la coved 19 est devenue hors
de contrôle en catalogne une personne
malade en contamine plus de 3 et ce sont
les jeunes qui sont le plus touchés il
faut le rappeler on est dans un contexte
de deux semaines juste après la fête de
la saint jean
c'est une célébration très populaire ici
à barcelone et il avait réuni beaucoup
de monde dans les rues et sur les plages
alors bien sûr cette annonce de
fermeture c'est un véritable coup de
massue pour le secteur du monde de la
nuit qui devait déjà travaillé avec un
protocole sanitaire très stricts tels
monstres
caen fait une discothèque sur deux avec
décidé de ne pas rouvrir quand elle le
pouvait alors face à cette possibilité
de cinquième vague
le gouvernement catalan misto sur la
vaccination aujourd'hui tous les
catalans de plus de 16 ans sont invitées
à se faire vacciner et à une vaccination
en échange de places pour les matchs de
l'euro 2000 20 c'est ce que le maire de
londres 1 propose à ses concitoyens
objectif accélérer la campagne de
vaccination et lutter contre la hausse
des contaminations liées aux variants
delta sur le territoire britannique
si vous vous rendez dans un centre sans
rendez vous pour recevoir le vaccin ou
si vous prenez rendez vous pour vous
faire vacciner vous pouvez vous inscrire
à un tirage au sort où il sera possible
de gagner une paire de billets pour
assister à la finale de l'euro ce
dimanche à wembley et 50 autres paires
de billets pour voir le match en
exclusivité sur la place trafalgar
c'est une opportunité unique et nous
espérons qu'au temps de londoniens que
possible j'ai profiteront de
l'incitation à gagner ces billets pour
obtenir le vaccin qui les restrictions
sanitaires souvenir dès le 19 juillet le
port du masque ou la distanciation
sociale ne seront plus obligatoire le
premier ministre lee johnson a annoncé
hier soir pourtant des scientifiques et
des médecins s'y oppose fermement et
précision de manière souple et comme un
air de retour à la vie normale et de
liberté bientôt retrouver au royaume uni
boris johnson a annoncé ce lundi la
dernière étape de la levée des
restrictions
tout en appelant désormais au bon sens
de chacun
nous allons supprimer toutes les limites
légales sur le nombre de personnes se
réunissant à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur
nous autoriserons la réouverture de tous
les commerces et compris les boîtes de
nuit mais lèveront la limite sur les
visiteurs nommé dans les maisons de
soins et sur le nombre de personnes
assistant à des concerts des pièces de
théâtre des événements sportifs
nous mettrons fin à la règle de la
distance sociale de plus d'un mètre et à
l'obligation légale de porter un masque
bien que des conseils suggèreront les
endroits où vous pourriez choisir de le
faire
en particulier lorsque les cas sont en
augmentation et lorsque vous entrez en
contact avec des personnes que vous ne
rencontrez pas normalement dans des
espaces clos tels que les transports
publics
manifestement bondés des mesures qui
devaient initialement prendre y fait le
21 juin mais qui ont été repoussées au
19 juillet face à la propagation du
variant delta difficile à contrôler le
gouvernement doit toutefois confirmé
cette décision le 12 juillet après la
réouverture des bars et restaurants en
avril dernier les boîtes de nuit
rouvriront à leur tour et les
restrictions de georges dans les
événements seront supprimés le
télétravail ne sera plus une obligation
cette stratégie axée sur la
responsabilité des citoyens à gérer tout
seul le virus est fortement remise en
question notamment par le chef de
l'opposition et bien l'annoncent ne
concerne que les gros titres et ne
concerne pas la santé publique
le premier ministre a dit qu'il avait se
laisser guider par les données et pas
par les dates elle n'a pas encore les
données
il ne les aura pas avant la fin de la
semaine il est encore en mesure de
prendre une décision avant lundi
prochain vous devez donc vous demandez à
quoi rime l'annoncent d'aujourd'hui si
le premier ministre insiste pour
rappeler que la pandémie est loin d'être
derrière le royaume uni
il souhaite malgré tout mettre fin à la
quarantaine pour les résidents
britanniques ayant reçu les deux
injections et venant d'un pays classé
orange
à l'image de la france de l'italie ou de
l'espagne
cette suppression quasi totale des
restrictions est en partie justifiée par
une campagne de vaccination massive au
royaume uni depuis début décembre
64 % de la population adulte a
complètement été vaccinés et 86% a reçu
une première injection
le 19 juillet prochain les autorités
espèrent que deux tiers de la population
sera totalement vacciner face à la
situation sanitaire
l'écossé l'irlande ont opté pour une
levée des mesures plus lente que celle
de leurs voisins angles et en tunisie à
présent le président de la république a
provoqué une réunion crise objective
venir à bout de cette quatrième vague de
covin en accélérant les campagnes
vaccinales notamment le personnel
soignant lui réclame des réformes en
urgence la correspondance depuis tunis
de personnes chez lui c'est une réunion
d'urgence convoquée lundi par le
président de la république qui n'a fait
que mettre en exergue les conséquences
que la crise politique et
institutionnelle engagé depuis six mois
a eu sur les affaires du pays parmi
lesquels la crise du coronavirus
recrudescence des contaminations kovy 19
avec un bilan inédit qui dépasse en
seize mois le chiffre de 15 mille 500
décès système sanitaire obsolète
hôpitaux encombrés ou encore personnels
soignants dépasser la tunisie semble
traverser une telle crise politique elle
semble avoir pris le pas sur le
règlement de la crise sanitaire pendant
ce temps les professionnels de santé
multiplie les appels pour réformer en
urgence un système sanitaire au bord du
gouffre alors que de son côté le
président de la république a décidé de
prendre des mesures strictes et
d'accélérer la campagne vaccinale en
multipliant les contacts avec les pays
producteurs de doses mais les critiques
fusent notamment sur le temps qu'il a
fallu au pays pour prendre conscience de
la situation sanitaire et de la gestion
de celle-ci et leur campagne de
vaccination avait été mené tambour
battant et le pays cité en exemple
pourtant israël connaît un rebond
nombre de contaminations le variant
delta touche le pays et n'épargne pas
des personnes vaccinées plus de 300
personnes recensées ces dernières 24
heures parmi elles beaucoup d'enfants en
fait point sur la situation avec antoine
ogier 55% de la population complètement
vaccinés
pourtant israël subit à son tour
l'impact du variant delta dans le pays
343 nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés ces
dernières 24 heures établissant le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées à plus
de 2500 dont 35 dans un état grave et 17
sous respirateur artificiel
principale source d'inquiétude le profil
des nouveaux contaminés car sur les 343
détecter la moitié serait des enfants il
y assez de vaccins pour tout le monde
mais il y à un hic leur validité va
bientôt expirer et nous n'aurons alors
plus assez de vaccins pour tout le monde
cela signifie qu'il y à une courte
fenêtre de 11 jours et que nous sommes
dans une course contre la montre
par conséquent j'appelle les parents
tous les adolescents filles et garçons
qui peuvent se faire vacciner à le faire
dès maintenant et ce avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
un message qui semble avoir été bien
reçu par la population
jusqu'à présent nous avons constaté que
les jeunes de 12 à 15 ans ont bien
accepté le vaccin à ce jour nous en
avons vacciné 45000 nous avons prévu
d'en vacciner
vingt mille autres sets deux prochaines
semaines nous constatons également avec
la dernière vague de pique et certains
enfants scolarisés une plus grande
réponse de la part des adolescents plus
âgés ceux de plus de 16 ans qui sont
également intéressés pour se faire
vacciner
l'autre moitié de ces nouveaux
contaminée est constitué d'adultes dont
plus de 5 millions sur les six que
compte le pays sont déjà complètement
vaccinés
pour le président du groupe d'experts
national israélien sur le co vie de 19
le fait que des vaccinés soit contaminée
prouve que l'efficacité du vaccin est
moindre sur les cas modérés du variant
delta mais pas totalement inefficace et
d'assez il semble toutefois que les
vaccins soient efficaces peut-être pas
dans la même mesure mais ils sont
efficaces pour prévenir la
ces nominations et nous espérons que la
combinaison du mur de vaccins que nous
avons créé avec certaines mesures
supplémentaires que nous prenons y
compris mais les masques et certaines
mesures supplémentaires sera suffisante
pour contenir davantage la maladie à ce
stade pour faire face à cette situation
les autorités sanitaires se réunit ce
mardi soir au programme des discussions
le retour du passeport vert pour
réserver l'accès à certains lieux aux
seules personnes vaccinées ou guéris du
coronavirus une éventuelle troisième
dose de vaccin pour les malades
chroniques ou encore une limitation du
public lors de certains rassemblements
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
la réforme des retraites sera t-il le
sujet brûlant de la rentrée la sortie de
la réunion des comptes entre syndicats
patronat emmanuel macron aucune décision
n'a été prise
et puis enfin un retour sur l'insomnie
de notre dame de paris une nouvelle
plainte doit être déposée en justice
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
dénonçant de graves négligences
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement des dissidents
par votre mouvement si des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé les les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont servis est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'intervention pour laisser les
sahraouis le choix de choisir le futur
de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie du territoire
marocain
[Musique]
merci on a identifié un peu plus de 500
depuis un an et demi les alertes
concernant les menaces de prédation sur
des entreprises françaises se
multiplient en vous avez un pays qui est
affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
ça intéresse les prédateurs parce qu'ils
savent que vous ne pourrez pas vous
défendre
ça peut le chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous actuellement dans cette guerre
économique et le darwinisme classique et
économiques et les gros mangent les
petits mais là on se trouve devant un
nouveau type de risque le droit est
maintenant utilisée par les états pour
aider leurs entreprises notamment à
affaiblir d'autres entreprises
étrangères
tous les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'économie ne savent pas ce
que c'est qu'une entreprise puisse y ont
jamais mis les pieds
donc ne leur demandez pas à défendre
quelque chose qu'ils ne connaissent pas
[Musique]
oh
il
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie de
taxis en france l'activité a reprise
d'apaisement dans paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de tourisme
étranger
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé ya bien cinq six ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivé là
concurrents mais vt gros gros choc
d'offre on est passé de on a on a doublé
les 20000 à 45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez les
partenaires sociaux à l'elysée
aujourd'hui une réunion je cite des
coûte avant de possibles annonces plus
tard en juillet peut-être principal
dossier le plan de relance économique
post crise sanitaire mais aussi et
surtout en toile de fond le brûlant
dossier de la réforme des retraites
alors qu emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer
ce sujet d'ici au 14 juillet le point
avec lucas léger devant le palais
présidentiel
c'est une réunion tour d'horizon sur la
sortie de crise qui a eu lieu pendant
trois heures à l'elysée avec des membres
de l'exécutif et les partenaires sociaux
a été présent le président bien sûr mais
aussi le premier ministre jean castex la
ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes où le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire ainsi que des
représentants des syndicats notamment la
cfdt la cgt fo la cfe cgc ou la cftc et
des représentants du patronat le medef
la cgpme ou lui 2 p tous les sujets ont
été abordés notamment le sujet épineux
de la réforme des retraites elles
avaient été suspendues pendant la crise
du coc vide 19 mai elles avaient
déclenché de fortes controverses
avant cela avec notamment les syndicale
prévoyait la suppression des quarante
deux régimes existants pour la remplacer
par un régime universel à point le
gouvernement évoque cette possibilité et
cette réforme
depuis quelques temps je vous propose
d'écouter notamment ce qu'a dit
elisabeth bornes après cette réunion
devant les députés une réforme des
retraites est nécessaire pour faire
évoluer notre système vers un verre plus
d'universalité d'équité et de
soutenabilité et c'est pour cette raison
que nous devrons travailler un peu plus
longtemps dans les années qui viennent
mais c'est dans les changes avec les
français les organisations syndicales et
patronales et les forces politiques que
nous trouverons les bonnes réponses
mais les syndicats ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille ils ne veulent pas pour la
plupart entendre parler d'un allongement
de la durée de travail
même d'une réforme dans un contexte de
retour de crise je vous propose
d'écouter à yves veyrier le secrétaire
général de force ouvrière qui
s'exprimait avant cette rencontre
je pense que c'est le bon timing
personnes les salariés n'en veulent pas
ils l'ont signifié de sur le plan
économie sociale je voulais y est la
priorité des priorités c'est l'emploi
j'ai suffisamment expliqué avant même la
crise sanitaire
la solution aux retraites c'est l'emploi
c'est la même chose sur l'assurance
chômage est trois je ne pense pas que ça
serait la meilleure décidé que d'en
faire un enjeu électoraliste enjoint
emmanuel macron a déclaré que cette
réforme des retraites ne pouvait pas
être reprise en l'état c'est à dire dans
l'état dans lequel elle avait été
laissée en 2020 il devrait clarifier sa
position et son agenda avant le 14
juillet mais une inconnue risque de
s'inviter dans ses plans la coupe 19 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec joseph
thouvenel secrétaire confédéral de la
cftc bonsoir joseph thouvenel merci
d'être avec nous une réforme des
retraites en septembre
clairement ça pourrait relancer les
gilets jaunes dans la rue et pas que
d'ailleurs clairement pour qui une
réforme il faut qu'ils aient une
acceptabilité de cette réforme et il me
semble que quoi qu'on pense sur le fond
l'acceptabilité n'y est pas pour
différentes raisons la première si on
l'a vu le pouvoir politique est
marginalisé 70 % de personnes qui ne
vont pas voter le la majorité entre
guillemets présidentiel faisant un
chiffre epsilon ça ne porte pas une
majorité à pouvoir prendre des décisions
l'acceptabilité c'est aussi la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans le politique
et quand j'entends des minutes et ce
qu'ils disent ne vous inquiétez eu de
réforme elle se fera dans un large au
dessus et bien
j'entends aussi les mêmes qui nous avait
dit qu'une réforme qui touchait la ville
et biotechnologies serait dans un large
consensus
ils ne l'ont pas fait et donc le temps
me semble pas venu pour réformer sur les
retraites surtout y at il urgence
y at il urgence m ou yann nécessité tout
de même parce que tout le monde semble
s'accorder à dire qu'il ya une forme de
nécessité dans cette réforme ce n'est
pas votre avis mais quelle d'abord la
réforme elle et elle est en cours sur
les retraites en permanence
je rappellerai simplement que pour les
salariés du privé on était il ya pas si
longtemps à 36 ans de cotisations on est
passé à 42 ans et maintenant ses 43 ans
que l'on prenait pour les salariés du
privé
la dernière année puis les 10 meilleures
années puis les 25 meilleures années
qu'on calcule et avec une indexation sur
l'inflation et maintenant c'est sur les
salaires c'est dire que la réforme des
retraites
elle est faite en permanence qu'on nous
dise pas que ce n'est pas fait qu'on ne
dise pas que les salariés du privé n'ont
pas fait des efforts considérables ces
dernières années passées de 36 cents à
43 ans ce n'est pas rien passé de la
dernière année pour calculer la retraite
aux 25 meilleures années
ce n'est pas rien alors maintenant on va
me dire oui mais un problème de budget
alors le coût des retraites c'était en
tout cas en 2018 c'est le dernier
chiffre qu'on est exact 310 milliards
d'euros oui mais c'est pas un coup parce
que ses 310 milliards d'euros ils
repartent dans la consommation
ils permettent aux gens de payer des
loyers d'acheter de logement et donc il
faudrait considérer les choses dans leur
réalité
les retraites c'est aussi ce qui permet
au pays de fonctionner et gîtes en crise
du coc vide qu'on avait la capacité tout
d'un coup de nous sortir des ea et
comment se fait-il que pour l'essayer
pour leur assurer une retraite décente
la machine à euro ne pourrait pas
fonctionner mes pensées pour le coc vide
elle peut fonctionner j'aimerais
comprendre aujourd'hui clairement quel
est le choix d' emmanuel macron de ne
rien faire au risque d'être taxé de roy
feignants qui me tient pas ses promesses
ou de trop faire est de mettre tout le
monde dans la rue
il est piégé clairement sur ce dossier
emmanuel macron il s'est sans doute
piéger tout seul mais le choix c'est
quoi le choix c'est de poser les choses
pour que chaque personne qui aura
travaillé toute sa vie puisse vivre
dignement et ce qui sort de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui c'est nous allons
réfléchir ensemble pour la cftc
oui je réfléchisse on regarde
regardons les métiers particulièrement
pénible est-ce qu'il faut les bouger
comment faut-il les bouger et mon aux
finances est leur retraite mais encore
des réserves considérables
il n'y a pas une urgence absolue et si
on se projette à une horizon de 20 25
ans on s'aperçoit que la masse du baby
boom qui était déjà en retraite battitta
petit elle va disparaître parce que
comme chaque être humain nous sommes
mortels est donc cette grande masse va
disparaître et donc le coût des
retraites bat mécaniquement baisser
aussi il faut mettre ça sur la table
tranquillement et non pas se précipiter
sur un débat qui est plus politicien que
réelle
pourtant joseph thouvenel si on revient
à séduire impasse quelques vides entre
temps quelques mois en arrière un peu
plus d'un an même le gouvernement nous
disait mais nous on a parfaitement
concerter les partenaires sociaux
d'ailleurs la loi voilà était quasiment
passé 1
donc qu'est-ce que vous répondez au
gouvernement tabassé c'est très simple
discuter avec les partenaires sociaux
recueillir leur avis ça veut pas dire de
la part du gouvernement et c'est normal
le gouvernement gouverne être d'accord
avec les partenaires sociaux
on voit bien qu'il ya des différences et
lens entre organisations syndicales y
ait des différences avec les
organisations patronales le gouvernement
son rôle c'est de gouverner notre rôle
ou en tout cas syndicalistes de la cftc
c'est de représenter et défendre les
salariés
en prenant en compte le bien commun
c'est-à-dire l'activité de l'ensemble du
pays
il nous semble que lens qui est proposée
pour les retraites c'est ce qui était
proposé
il y avait des choses avec lesquelles on
était d'accord et d'autres avec lesquels
on n'était pas d'accord
par exemple faire baisser les retraites
pour les cadres qui cotisent beaucoup et
qui sont largement bénéficiaires ne nous
semble pas juste
merci joseph à tout venant je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire confédéral de
la cftc
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rci rouen ce rassemblement cet après
midi devant l'hôtel de ville de paris un
regroupement à l'appel des sympathisants
du mouvement ça cache paris protestent
contre la politique de la majorité
municipale revendication principale
l'absence de propreté dans les rues de
paris et à la saleté il ya le manque de
considération des administrés la voirie
les terrasses n'importe comment sans
réglementation les vélos qui font
n'importe quoi
les piétons qui sont en danger tout le
temps elle allait le mobilier volée et
surtout en plus remplacées par des trucs
il de mai
mais il y deux merveilles arrière bien
rien de bien commerçants associations
professionnelles politiques citoyens
tout le monde doit réagir sinon paris va
être saccagée défiguré et la paire de
son commerce
paris est devenue de plus en plus sales
paris et saccagé au niveau de travaux
n'importe où n'importe comment
on a fermé les quais de seine et ça a
accentué sa congestionné tout paris avec
la fermeture de la voie georges pompidou
qui fluidifier la circulation à paris et
bien c'est est peut-être l'une des plus
graves et mauvaise décision de la mairie
de paris
mais la cathédrale de notre dame de
paris accusé de mettre la vie d'autrui
en danger une branche départementale de
la cgt une association et deux familles
de riverains ont déposé ce mardi une
plainte contre x en cause la pollution
au plomb provoquée par l'incendié du 15
avril 2019 qui n'auraient pas été pris
au sérieux
les plaignants estiment qu'aucune mesure
suffisante n'a été prise pour protéger
la santé des habitants et des ouvriers
et ce malgré des avertissements répétés
de l'inspection du travail et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec benoît
martin secrétaire général de l'union
départementale de la cgt paris bonsoir
benoît martin merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous donc cette nouvelle plainte a pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui qui
est pointée du doigt en quoi la ville de
paris est elle responsable selon vous
alors c'est qu'on dira ce dépôt de
plainte vise toutes les personnes
morales ou physiques dont la l'enquêté
dabira qu'ils ont fait preuve de
négligence donc il n'y a pas que la
ville de paris un éventuellement
potentiellement il a également dit
petit problème avec benoît martin on ne
sait pas s'il a cette connexion réseau
va se rétablir non ça ne semble pas
malheureusement on va poursuivre avec
l'ibiza guèye est une affaire qui refait
surface en autriche heinz christian
strache en scène tête des fiches de plus
de la plus grande formation de
l'ultra-droite du pays est jugé pour
corruption aujourd'hui en 2017 l'homme a
été piégé lors de vacances dans les îles
baléares une caméra cachée qui a
bouleversé le paysage politique
autrichien s'il est reconnu coupable
ce rachat pourrait être condamné à une
peine de prison allant de six mois à
cinq ans retour sur les faits avec m il
romagnan et cyrielle benavides bullion
tout commence en 2017 à ibiza lorsque
heinz christian strache chef du fpr le
parti autrichien de la liberté rencontre
une femme se présentant comme la riche
nièce d'un oligarque russe
voulant investir en autriche lors d'une
soirée arrosée il lui propose de
participer de manière occulte au
financement de sa campagne en échange
s'il devait entrer au gouvernement
il promet de lui faire remporter des
appels d'offres émis par les pouvoirs
public autrichien heinz christian
strache a en fait été piégé l'entrevue a
été filmé en caméra cachée deux ans plus
tard en mai 2019
le scandale éclate lorsque la presse
allemande révèle des extraits de la
vidéo
heinz christian strache est alors vice
chancelier et son parti de droite
radicale le fp e membre du gouvernement
grâce à une coalition avec les
conservateurs du chancelier sebastian
kurz ces révélations l'obliger à
démissionner et font chuter le
gouvernement
des élections législatives anticipées
sont organisés le séisme politique est
également un séisme judiciaire le
parquet a ordonné l'ouverture d'une
douzaine denquête notamment pour
corruption
dans cette vidéo le chef du fps déclaré
notamment que des milliardaires mais
aussi le géant autrichien du jeu
d'argent novomatic finances et
illégalement la classe politique
les enquêtes ont conduit à la saisine de
plusieurs téléphones portables dont
celui de heinz christian strache ce qui
a permis de l'inculper pour corruption
en cause des échanges de messages entre
le chef du fpr est un donateur du parti
ou heinz christian strache promet à ce
propriétaire d'une clinique privée de
rattacher son établissement à la
sécurité sociale
une fois au pouvoir il a modifié la
législation sa faveur heinz christian
strache et toutes les personnes mises en
cause dans ce procès n'est les faits qui
leur sont reprochés
concernant les propos tenus dans la
vidéo l'ancien vice-chancelier les met
sur le compte de la boisson et affirme
même avoir été drogué à son insu et nous
avons récupéré
forte heureusement benoît martin
secrétaire général de l'union
départementale de la cgt paris après une
petite coupure de deux réseaux ont parlé
de cette plainte un benoît martin avec
vous pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui après l'incendié de notre dame
la ville de paris je répète ma question
de tout à l'heure en quoi est elle
responsable selon vous alors nous avons
porté plainte contre quiconque aurait
joué un rôle pour dire en termes de
négligence à par rapport à toutes les
expositions aux risques du plomb
donc il n'y a pas que la ville de paris
qui est visé il ya un certain nombre
d'employeurs du public comme du privé
il ya les autorités en général la ville
pourquoi pas la préfecture pourquoi pas
l' agence régionale de santé le
ministère de la culture etc
le ministère du travail donc voilà il ya
tout un ensemble d'acteurs qui ont joué
un rôle et qui ont minimisé les risques
qui les ont même parfois nier 1 et qui
pourrait être impliquée dans cette
affaire mais nous notre dépôt de plainte
vise en général tous les acteurs qui
auront fait preuve de
négligence il ya eu des alertes qui
n'auront pas été assez prises en compte
c'est bien cela oui alors les alertes
ont émané non seulement de notre
collectif constitué de deux syndicats
cgt de deux associations
et puis des parents également des
familles des parents d'élèves parmi les
plaignants il ya la société une
association mais également de deux
familles dont les enfants en découdront
eu des taux de plomb dans dans le sens
extrêmement élevé donc oui il ya eu des
négligences eux il ya un déni de la
gravité de cette pollution au plomb les
400 tonnes qui ont été répandues dans
l'atmosphère ces formes de poussière
sont retombés 1 voilà et ont contaminé
les gens donc évidemment toutes les
alertes qui ont eu lieu en vente et
manning de notre collectif mais
également de l'inspection du travail
l'inspection du travail avait quand même
rendu un rapport l'été 2010 9
j'ai conduit est bien au fait que le
chantier avait été suspendu un an ils
étaient 2000 19 noms des deux alertes il
y en a eu de très nombreuses pourquoi il
n'y a pas eu de confinement total du
chantier comme c'était d'ailleurs
demandé un parler les associations les
ouvriers n'ont pas été assez protégé au
non plus voilà exactement un confinement
de l'édifice l'autre dame et était tout
à fait possible
il ya même eu des études dans ce sens
décidément quand ça veut pas ça ne veut
pas benoît martin on a entendu en tout
cas l'essentiel de votre message
nouvelle plainte donc la part notamment
de la cgt pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui après cet incendiaire de notre
dame et la ville de paris qui est
notamment pointée du doigt dans le reste
de l'actualité incertitudes en
afghanistan au lendemain d'un nouvel
exode massif de soldats vers le
tadjikistan voisin en cause
l'inexorable percée des talibans qui
viennent de prendre le contrôle d'une
dizaine de districts en peu de temps
selon les autorités tadjikes plus d'un
millier de militaires afghans ont battu
en retraite je suis pour sauver leur vie
le président tadjik a ordonné la
mobilisation de 20000 réservistes pour
renforcer la frontière alors que moscou
a annoncé de son côté la fermeture
provisoire d'un des consulats dans le
nord du pays une situation chaotique qui
fait suite au départ le week-end dernier
de troupes américaines et de l'otan de
la base militaire de bagram la plus
importante du pays
les soldats afghans plus que jamais
livrés à eux mêmes avec des milliers de
prisonniers talibans sur leurs gardes et
la certitude d'une attaque imminente des
insurgés islamistes
au grand dam d'ailleurs de la population
grâce d'aia le langage du corps comme
exutoire manie sera à 18 ans et c'est
dans le breakdance qu'elle a choisi de
s'exprimer dans cette cour de kaboul
elle s'entraîne avec son groupe dont
elle est la seule femme le jour où j'ai
décidé de faire du breakdance g peser
les pour et les contre même si je suis
attaqué pour mon travail ça a de la
valeur parce que je suis une fille qui a
choisi avec tout mon courage cette
discipline parce que je voulais ouvrir
la voie aux autres filles qui ne peuvent
pas le faire
auparavant nous n'avions pas de femmes
policières maintenant vous en voyez
partout et tout le monde en est fier au
début quelqu'un a été la pionnière et à
paver le chemin pour que d'autres femmes
rejoignent les rangs de la police
je veux également être ce genre de fille
pour les autres la majorité de son
groupe et chiite hazara une minorités
ethniques considérés comme hérétiques
par les musulmans radicaux le breakdance
qui intégrera les jo de 2024 donne
l'espoir fou à la jeune femme de pouvoir
et représenter son pays sans risque un
rêve qui pourrait s'écrouler si les
talibans revenez en force
autre femme autre univers à l'étagé dans
des salons les plus prisés de kaboul
c'est dans la beauté que farida a choisi
d'exceller aujourd'hui elle s'occupe
d'une marée
en ce moment nous les femmes nous
pouvons être ensemble nous pouvons
travailler se maquiller est allé
librement partout où bon nous semble
mais si les talibans reviennent nous
n'aurons plus jamais la liberté que nous
avons maintenant une coquetterie de
circonstance facturé entre 200 et plus
de 500 euros totalement interdite par
les talibans une crainte de retour du
passé aussi pour la gente masculine ou
se faire couper les cheveux ou tailler
la barbe sont également menacés il
s'agit pourtant de secteurs porteurs qui
ont contribué à la reprise économique du
pays qui a vu son pib par habitant passé
d'un peu plus de 500 dollars en 2018 à
592 $ cette année et c'est l'agriculture
qui emploie 42 % de la population reste
le secteur principal de l'activité
économique et services occupent
désormais une part primordiale en
employant près de 40% de la population
et représentant plus de la moitié des
pib de leurs côtés les talibans sont
déterminés à reprendre le contrôle sur
la base militaire de soul funk il
récemment reprise ils font étalage des
armes saisies et hissent leur drapeau
comme il n'est pas prendre mi-novembre
la seule chose qui me persuadera de
poser mon arme et qu'il est ici une loi
islamique est entièrement basé sur
l'islam et que le gouvernement soit
dirigé selon les règles islamiques sur
le territoire depuis 2001 les militaires
américains ont discrètement quitté leur
dernière grande base aérienne à
proximité de kaboul
les sens encore un peu plus le champ
libre aux talibans et privant
probablement ainsi les afghans d'une vie
de liberté morale mais aussi économiques
une culture en péril des emplois menacés
et toute une économie à réinventer après
vingt ans de conflit
poursuit avec l'actualité sur le
continent africain le nigeria une
nouvelle fois touché par un enlèvement
de masse dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi 140 lycéens ont été enlevés dans
leur championnat par des hommes armés
dans l'état de kaduna
les précisions de france pâtissier pitch
les impacts de balles témoignent de la
violence de l'attaqué dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi entre 1h et 2h du matin
des hommes armés arrivés à pied pénètre
dans le pensionnat du lycée bethel à
chikhoune dans l'état de kaduna
au total sur les 165 lycéens qui
dormaient dans l'établissement 140 ont
été kidnappés tandis que 25 ont réussi à
s'échapper rassemblé près de l'école les
parents en colère contre les autorités
attendent des nouvelles de leurs enfants
nous parlons d'une seule voix nous avons
condamné ce qui s'est passé et nous
manifesterons et nous continuerons de
manifester jusqu'à ce que nos enfants
soient de retour
nous continuerons de parler nous feront
du bruit nous appelons la communauté
internationale
nous appelons toute personne qui est en
position de pouvoir remédier à nos
problèmes de nous venir en aide
nous ne recevons plus des deux venait
nous en herbe le pape parole de la
police de l'état indiqué que ces hommes
avaient pris en chasse les ravisseurs et
que l'opération était toujours en cours
tandis que le président nigérian
muhammadu buhari a ordonné dans un
communiqué à l'armée la police et aux
services de renseignement devrait à la
libération rapide de toutes les victimes
enlevées
une nouvelle attaque commise dans cet
état la troisième en autant de jours
dimanche une dizaine d'employés d'un
hôpital ont été enlevés et sept
personnes ont été tuées dans des
attaques sporadiques dans des localités
voisines
des agissements attribuées à des groupes
criminels communément appelée bandits
par les autorités dans le nord ouest et
le centre du nigeria ils attaquent des
villages écoles ou universités vol du
bétail ou enlèvent sur les routes des
personnalités locales et des voyageurs
contre rançon mais contrairement à
certains de ses homologues des états
voisins
le gouverneur de l'état de kaduna adopte
une position ferme
refusant catégoriquement de négocier
avec ces groupes armés et de payer les
rançons demandées très écoles de la
région considérées comme vulnérables ont
été fermés ce lundi par les autorités
depuis début décembre ce sont plus de
mille enfants adolescents et étudiants
qui ont été enlevés dans une douzaine
d'attac
certains d'entre eux sont toujours aux
mains de leurs ravisseurs
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain compresseur la
qualité dans quelques minutes avec mona
amoud et laure excellente fin de soirée
à tous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui compte l on soit
vient des lignes aujourd'hui on a une
gauche l'extrême musée d'ananas de ses
conclusions